all right we're gonna we're gonna get
started with uh division three it's uh
12 43 13 minutes 30 minutes later than
we
had recessed ourselves into
uh the extra time was necessary
because um um mr ripple uh and the ols
were working on
getting
some very small things cleaned up so
that so that represent waller can look
at a perfect copy
uh so
um
we
i hope we can move through this fairly
rapidly because uh we have a hard break
at a little bit before two o'clock
so uh we'll try to honor that
um and so i i i made i'm i may try some
techniques to to move us a little bit
quicker
has everyone here
had an opportunity to look at least at
least at at least one
version of the drafts
i i cannot hear you well we're talking
okay so so by uh yes represent walnut
yeah
um
i wondered if it's going to be possible
for
maybe kevin to walk through
with us
and show us because i'm looking at this
and
it's
it would be very hard for anyone to take
a look at this and
know the difference between this
amendment
and how the bill came to us
so if kevin could walk through
the changes from the bill that we
received uh sure and and he's prepared
to do that we talked about it beforehand
so if um so with that i guess mr ripple
uh would you start walking us through uh
what came to the committee and where
we're at
um sure well what i'm prepared to do is
talk to you about the differences
between this version
and the version
okay thanks
uh and the version that i emailed out uh
yesterday afternoon
so when you say this version i i think
you mean that the the newest latest
greatest is version number one eight six
four that's correct
okay so i as i understood representative
wallner's request
is that she she would like us also to
touch on
the bill as introduced
and not just from
amendment 1846 which i think is what you
emailed out
um and i think i might need a couple
minutes uh in order to
in order to do that and compare this to
the original bill
okay um did did every okay all right i i
want to give you time
uh
i i i
or are you going to be okay if we just
go from 1846 to
1864. you you want it from the uh bill
is introduced
i would like it from the bill as
introduced as it came from health and
human services that's a very fair it's a
very fair
request
and it would really be great to not hear
the word policy committee too many times
today
so the one we started with
i believe it has an amendment number
that was approved by the house 1678
so that
i i think that's everybody's baseline
do you have a copy of that
okay
all right well i have a couple different
uh
marked up versions over here but i can
make an attempt to go through
the changes between this and the bill as
it first came to us
so in section one the first paragraph
lines eight through fourteen
a health facility is defined a bit
an urgent care network of three or more
clinics licensed under rsa 151 whereas
previously it read an urgent care center
licensed under rsa
that was one of the changes proposed by
representative irf
yesterday
it also states on lines 10 through 12
that a health facility shall not include
state-operated medical facilities and
voluntary compliance by a state-operated
facility shall not subject such facility
to the requirements of this section
and then on lines 13 and 14 uh we have a
term that's a bit duplicative with
what's on line nine but i've been uh
told that it isn't a difficulty and
that's that the term health facility
shall not include any
non-hospital-affiliated urgent care with
less than three clinics in new hampshire
essentially the same thing as was
already on line nine mr chair
i'm sorry representing oregon can i just
ask you a quick question so
we we have this document that you gave
us right we're not looking at them i i
know that's i just wanted to clarify
we're we're going back to once
we're going back to the original 1678.
right the short answer is yes we're
doing what representative wallner asked
us to do three minutes ago which was to
go from the version that was introduced
to us to the most recent version the
most recent version
is one eight six four right
okay
all right
okay so on lines 15 and 16
at
representative edward's request and this
is based on the marked up version that
he handed out that you handed out
yesterday representative edwards um
workplace violence definition has been
shortened
to end at other threatening behavior
there was previously more to that
sentence
a new c has been added on lines 17
through 19
may i ask you a question about that and
uh honor representative walls who's gone
but not forgotten
uh she she wanted to know
if we were reusing terms that already
exist in statute elsewhere do you know
if ols considered that question
i don't know i asked them to take a look
at this definition in particular and
are there any questions on that
representative
so ols didn't had no
they they made no changes to that
definition that's correct
did they do we know if they checked it
against
i don't know
okay
thank you
i would like to say that if
we find over i i what i sort of think
we're trying to do here
is we're trying to find a way to say yes
to one another
put this canoe in the water
let all of these organizations start
paddling trying to get to where they're
trying to go
and
there's going to be another legislative
season so if we if we have to tweak this
um to for some
something that we've overlooked in this
process i think we can do that
particularly given that we in here we
specifically asked the commission to
report to um health and human services
oversight to let us know
what changes may be appropriate so
um i i i hope that we don't uh feel that
um
perfect needs to be the enemy of really
pretty good
so uh
mr ripple
sure
uh roman two starting on line twenty
there have been a couple changes
um
in particular that first sentence was
shortened the sentence that ends uh
maintain a violence
workplace violence prevention program
that was previously more extensive and
per representative edwards proposed
changes
was the language the program shall
consider the size and complexity of the
health facility and shall address the
following topics
and everything that follows down to the
i'm sorry
no i'm sorry a and b remain a and b were
in the original version
yes and b was shortened from the
i will note that throughout
there were references added to hostile
words where previously only workplace
is down in roman 5 on page 2
and there's now a reference to the chair
with the advice of the commission which
may recommend updates to statutes or the
rule making process
may i may i jump in and just
point out that on line 19 roman numeral
four is is new from what we received
you're correct that is also new right
what what we did was
uh this amendment adds that the
commissioner of the department of hhs
shall follow up on participation in the
workplace violence prevention program so
that the pro so that participation
status is proactively known and that
this status is properly reported in the
annual report
and
we're doing that to
meet one of the
concerns of the of the hospital
and the nursing association
that uh
there there there's needs to be uh
pressure
to make sure that these groups volunteer
voluntarily do their jobs i shouldn't
have used voluntarily because this is
meant to be a mandate so
so go ahead from room uh you have a
question on that yes i did
representative
i guess since it is a mandate i guess i
i don't really understand
why we need this in here
because i'm a lazy guy and i want to be
able to look at a website and see every
organization that's in the commission
and whether or not they are
participating
if i want to see that i would think
interested parties given that there
seems to be a bunch of them would also
like to have some public disclosure to
me this is a transparency issue
that also
uh
adds the kind of
pressure
to
these institutions to help motivate them
to comply by generating a bottoms-up
pressure for them to comply so if the
information is public and shareable
then
they have all that much more reason to
comply
do you have a problem with it it's
really the issue i
i mean i just think it's sort of
unnecessary to
have that kind of i i would disagree but
um but we'll end up voting on this
uh mr ripple
yep on romans 6 a starting on line 33
there was some language added to that
section
for example the annual report for the
calendar year ending december 31st
shall include but not necessarily be
and then the incidents cited here were
those that were
already in the bill again there were
some changes in a few additions for
example hostile words as mentioned on
on line six
the phrase but not any identifiable
when you get down to line
the percentage of employees that have
participated in the workplace violence
prevention program that language was
revised consistent with representative
edwards
i'm on page three yes that was line
b starting on line 22 was revised
slightly
to state that the report shall preserve
the distinction between workplace
it again repeats that there shall not be
any identifiable personal information
included in the report on line 24
or 23.
yes
roman 8 starting on line 34 is new and
that came from representative edwards
draft of yesterday this is the
requirement that the department maintain
a website
and it identifies
at the top of the next page page four
the topics to be included on that
website
i
so i think yesterday i talked i asked mr
williams a little bit about
the website and whether or not
this is going to be just another
tour for the department of health and
human services
and if this is going to entail
additional resources that they'll need
in order to to keep this website
current
and i wondered if
the department had given any further
so come on up and as you do as i re
recall yesterday's testimony you said
something to the effect that uh
that this is something that the
department could support that if it does
require additional manpower that we'll
include that in the next budget cycle
for the record john williams director of
legislative affairs for the new
hampshire department of health and
services and that is a very good recap
about what information i provided to
committee there's no change
to
that as of today's date
so would you anticipate that in the next
budget we will see
some additional i mean once you know how
much information
is this is going to generate and you'll
have to have it in the
yeah i think we're fortunate that the
effective data the bill
does allow the department of
um posting on the department's website
of the identified information in this
amendment there could be other resource
demands in the department that we'd like
to revisit
or at least have the flexibility to
revisit with the legislature
i would also say
representative walter keep in mind what
we one of the things that we've done
with this bill you can stay there or go
back
wherever you're comfortable um is that
the the prior
the version is introduced to us was
punitive it had a two thousand dollar
fines in it uh to be off done at the
commissioner's uh discretion so that
peop these organizations would um uh
comply
more of a free-market bottoms-up
approach of making sure that all the
interested parties
have the information necessary for them
to apply pressure locally and that gets
us out of the
coercive nature of fines and gets us out
of the discretionary nature of giving
the commissioner new authority to issue
fines against the select group of
hospitals so i it
i i i included it obviously because i
think it's a good idea but we spend
money all the time on uh public
transparency i mean though
you know youtube for example we weren't
doing this two years ago we're spending
money on this because it makes
us more transparent and that's and
that's what i'm trying to do with this
um mr ripple
okay and as you just mentioned um
the section about the two thousand
dollar fine was removed i believe it was
in this area of the bill it's now gone
we moved down to the newly established
workplace safety commission
i think the only change on this page is
down on lines 33
on line 33 the governor may remove any
i do have a question about the
commission
please
so now that um
member of
a hospital in new hampshire
so
is the state
run hospitals still have a
member on this i mean it wouldn't be
necessary because they are no longer
covered by
now the chief executive officer of the
new hampshire
new hampshire hospital it's number two
would that i mean why would that be
necessary
if they're not on because although we've
made it um
voluntary for the entirety of this uh
this still would represent the
the state
being involved and and being able to
know what's going on and to provide
advice what we heard in testimony is
that new hampshire hospital actually has
a pretty good workplace violence program
and that other institutions may want to
pick at the knowledge of the ceo and
adopt the best practices as
new hampshire hospital has perceived
them so this this is participation in
the commission not in the program that's
that's also a distinction we have a
commission and we have a program
so we've intended to have
the uh
program portion of it be voluntary
they can still opt to do it
it's just i'm i'm letting them know that
i i don't know that
we would support
a new budget for new fte but
uh representative long you have a
question yeah thank you mr chairman i i
i certainly understand the transparency
and and that is the goal here
uh but i'm looking at confusion from
confusions from people looking at this
that aren't intimate as we are with this
seeing a representative from new
hampshire hospital on there but not
seeing a listing whether the new
hampshire hospitals are active or
inactive
i you know i
you know so i'm i'm more concerned about
the public
going online and seeing
a representative of the hospital
but not seeing their status
uh i mean we know that they're already
proactive in this but the public doesn't
know that
so i think uh we're gonna get down to it
and i'm looking forward to seeing it but
i i think uh we we came up with new
categories of
active inactive and we kept
other or something like other so
something like a new hospital new
hampshire hospital
that that other flexibility in the
status could could potentially be used i
mean i'm not trying to micromanage the
writing of that report but that's what i
think could be done okay so there'll be
a listing of a healthcare facility
my understanding is that they're not so
so
mr ripple since this is uh
the heart of uh
representative long's uh comments
could you could you jump us down to the
um
reporting section or would it just be
better for us to
hang on and because we're going to get
to it naturally if we keep going
sequentially like this do you mind if
that's fine okay let's let's let's just
let's just stay on task and in sequence
and i think we're going to get to it
okay
so we left off on line 33 the governor
may remove any member of the commission
with cause i think the next change is on
page five
line 11 but the initial term of the
then there's no other change until line
19 where other than police reports was
added after all information
just say to everyone what we talked
about beforehand when this goes and
assuming this goes to enrolled bills
there's that tiny little typo on line 11
where the word terms should become term
i believe the next change is on the next
page
page six
on lines two and three
uh added to the end of that sentence was
provided that the information sharing
process shall include de-identification
of any personally identifiable
information
now now on this i noticed that they
removed my reference to the principle of
data minimization do you know what their
thinking was because that's actually its
own separate principle
i i don't know this was the language
that ols came up with i i think i did
provide your exact language but they
made some tweaks here and there
all right so um i i don't i don't care
to send this another amendment in for
that
so okay um
the next change is down on line nine
where and data privacy was added
on line 10 the reporting date was
chairman edwards could i
could
i know that the
the hospital association spoke about
the reports and how they wanted it to
mirror
the same process as the
as another group
the quality
yeah
i wondered how close we're marrying that
are we
is this
actually
th this is actually not
something that i'm really passionate
about i just thought that intellectually
these reports would be more useful to us
if they were
current
going into the budget year
so that we know what's going on
and and
uh and and if there are new bills to be
heard we've got the most current
information available to help us
consider the bill
i i don't i don't have a particular
um
point of interest or authorship in that
other than i thought it just made more
sense to make these
as important as this commission is let's
make these reports as useful as possible
by synchronizing the timing
so so i will get uh
give ms
um minihan an opportunity to come up and
address just various things but
let's get through all of these before we
get her out that was just one i don't
know what the process what the other
process is yeah the quality one it's
we're probably out of phase with the
quality because i'm sure if they took
the quality then they probably were
thinking july one you know but
we'll find out
so so mr ripple yeah i i don't know what
happened to
um the activator
yeah i had that section
on my notes it would
be in section eight right so that's
under the uh website maintained by hhs
so that's near the top of page four on
line three the website shall include the
participation status of each facility as
active inactive run oh okay
okay uh so it says unknown not other yep
so if we go back to page six
i think the last change i had mentioned
was the reporting date of january 31st
on line 10. right
and with the data as of december 31st i
think is what that means
okay correct and down on line
uh the advice incentive a majority of
consent of a majority of members of the
commission was changed to the advice of
members of the commission
and lines 22 through 24 are new and this
just reiterates that medical facilities
operated by the state are not subject to
the
commission established that follows
okay so since we had them as a member of
the commission is this written the way
well i still believe they're not subject
i think the only change remaining
is the repeal date of march 1st 2034 on
line 33. right so that's more than 10
years to
okay
so uh mr ripple has walked through the
changes
we have about 49 minutes
um yes ma'am could i ask mr ripple one
question yes so
um as we walk through here
i didn't see
in
chairman edwards's um
original
thoughts on this draft on this amendment
he had um
he cited the right to the freedom from
discrimination
um
a couple of times the bill has that been
dropped yeah it got dropped because uh
miss minahan was correct and i i was
wrong okay uh that uh she she
cited that that section of 354
wasn't applicable to the private
hospitals and i i thought it was i i
actually had done a lot of research on
354 and i'm surprised but okay great
thank you
anything else
no that that was my main one okay
so with that uh let's invite
ms minihan and mr thomas
if you could both
come up i think i think we're going to
be interested in knowing what your
reaction is and and i'd like to i also
asked um the president of the hospital
association steve and to join us oh sure
thank you so so i i want to i want to
basically color your comments uh with my
own crayon for a second
and and say what i what i think this
amendment has done
is it maintained all of the mandatory it
maintained the mandatory nature of the
program
while removing
fines
adding
public information and
public organic pressure to for these
organizations to respond and behave
um and that it uh doubled down on
emphasizing that we don't want
personally identifiable information
being distributed between the members of
the commission
so
so with that i'm happy to hear from you
however you want to proceed
um thank you mr chairman um against
steven president hospital association um
i actually just returned from a national
meeting with hospitals from across the
country
and talking to my colleagues who run
state hospital associations in other
states and i can assure you that this is
an incredibly important issue not just
in new hampshire it's an issue that
hospitals are facing all across the
country
and are looking for opportunities to to
do something many are doing different
things
but this is not an issue that's
solely here in new hampshire
this bill is an incredibly important
bill
of ours that hospitals sought to have
introduced this year because we want to
find a way to solve this problem to
prevent violence and to protect the
health care workforce that serves our
patients and our communities
so
i just want to be clear
we want
legislation to pass that supports our
hospitals and healthcare
heroes in doing the work that they do to
prevent violence um and ensure that they
work in a safe environment so let's just
make certain that everybody understands
that um so again we're looking at this
amendment obviously just saw this
version um today
and based upon what we had seen
yesterday i would say it's a
you know vast improvement um from from
what we had seen
i want to just ask a couple of questions
and then paula can speak more
specifically to various issues i
understand the notion that you wanted to
make this voluntary
that's a certainly a different approach
you've referenced though
by including a provision that the
commissioner is going to follow up and
post on websites as a means of
pressuring and you know sort of holding
people accountable to participate
i'm not
i wasn't we weren't asking this to be
mandatory because we were concerned that
people would not participate that's not
a concern that's not an issue um so i
just want to be clear we're not
anticipating that anybody anybody's
going to say i don't want to participate
because they believe this is important
as well
i'm not an attorney and so maybe this is
a concern that is is not a a relevant
one but when you've made
the state hospitals and state facilities
not a participant not subject to the
quality commission and i just want to be
certain that if the
state hospital and other state
facilities choose to participate in one
way or the other because you're right
they do have uh workplace safety
programs and and things in place that
we've actually shared and
helped educate other hospitals about
when they come to the commission and
share that information
i just want to make certain that when
they're doing so that those that
information maintains
the confidentiality protections that
everyone else who is subject to the
commission
is under so again
we've talked about that why that's
important and just wanting to make
certain that if somebody's coming to the
commission sharing information
participating voluntarily that somehow
they lose that confidentiality
protections that everybody else has
who's a part of the commission may i
address just that point
because i i'm not a lawyer
um
but uh but we're we're calling out
specifically as a member the
designee or the chief executive officer
of the new hampshire hospital that
they're specifically in writing a member
of this commission
and then in the confidentiality section
it it basically starts out that says all
of the information submitted to or
collected by the commission it shall be
confidential
uh so i to to just that one concern i i
i think we're good
okay
again i want to make certain that we're
not doing anything that would prevent
new hampshire hospital or somebody else
from sharing information um in a way
that could be discoverable and the like
all right and and i think it's covered
and because we're going to have an
ongoing at least annual relationship uh
with because i'm on the joint health and
human services
committee
um if there's an issue there
that comes up i don't think there will
be we we can address it
um so just
one other question or one other point
and um i think
kevin ripple
explained this and maybe i just didn't
hear it correctly
but it's on page 3 line 18 through 21
the percentage of employees that have
participated in the workplace violence
prevention program in the reporting year
immediately preceding the incident um
i'm just not i just want to understand
what we're asking so who how many
employees participated in the program
and was that in terms of education um
wasn't quite clear to me what we're
asking and what were what you're seeking
um to understand okay give me just a
second because um
this was a change from the original
um
okay if you go to the version that came
to us and i don't think you have it
necessarily
this this this area said
the percentage of employees that have
participated in the workplace violence
prevention program in the year preceding
the incident
so
so having had to do
data call reports in in in my past
the way i would interpret that is if i
have an incident on march 23rd
i have to calculate a new percentage
from like march 22 yesterday
to a year ago so that that each
incident that i reported would require a
separate
uh
data analysis and calculation of the
percentage so rather than leave that
ambiguity in there
what i attempted to do and maybe it's
just as ambiguous is is to say
it's it's it is sufficient to use the
percentage that got reported in the
annual report so that it doesn't have to
be recalculated on a contemporaneous
basis for every uh single incident that
okay
um and then the last thing i will
comment on relative to the timing of the
reports um as you know the new hampshire
healthcare quality and safety commission
which has been in existence for many
many years
has a reporting
date of on or before june 30. and the
value of that that i think we have found
is that when they make that report by
the you know it's usually june 1st of
each year
they present that they share that with
the speaker the president the senate the
governor with the hhs oversight
committee they actually present to the
hhs oversight committee it allows them
if there are changes that are necessary
that
would be contemplated under um you know
the the commission it gives them
time and the legislature time to
consider that as they're moving into the
coming year um from a legislative
perspective so that they then have the
ability to to get that sort of in
process so that by january one um when
the session begins that legislation is
is in place so i'm just going to cut you
off for because i agree with you if
that's if that's the way you view it if
that's the way you think this report is
going to be more useful to the the other
consumers of this report i'm i'm i'm
fine with uh putting the the dates
of the report
back to the way they were in the
original i i think the one thing we may
have added in this is
although the year ending is on a date i
guess you would pick june 30th
there's there's still another month
before the report has to be
um
produced
the way the way and then just interrupt
real quick the way the quality
commission um
does so it's on or before june 30th um
obviously the the fiscal year ends um
june 30. um they have traditionally
issued their report on june 1st um so
the the they're able to do that they
have their last meeting in may they're
able to make those recommendations and
put that together so that they have that
um done in a in a timely way i i i won't
i'll i'll support exactly what you just
said whatever you want i i thought i was
being helpful if i'm not being helpful
i'll just back out of that if i can if i
can take that uh you agree with whatever
i want
uh no it's a it's a very finite
we're dealing with dates but
you can't blame me for trying yeah so
the s so
so later we're going to have to make a
motion
and we're probably going to make a
motion that says pending the changes
you know so that we can keep moving
uh uh
representative wyler
so
the reason we
supported that
was
so we would have time
we started looking at the budget
february 15th
if there was something we needed to
change
that was in the budget that's a good
time now it's the latest data he wanted
the freshest data not something six
months eight months old
then
if it's a policy change we can do it in
hb2
if it's a if it's a
numbers change in the budget we can do
it in hb1 but we wanted the latest data
thinking as a finance committee
our actions start on february 15th
so if we're going to look for the latest
data that's why he chose that reporting
date understood and but i i think also
just for completeness um your point of
view would also just support the idea
that if there is a legislative change
and our windows open up in september for
new legislation that we're hitting that
new window as well so
i you know uh i
i it's either way and given that you
guys are going to have to live with this
i'm happy to go with the dates that you
prefer and i would just add you know to
the extent that there are issues that
are coming up that from a budgetary
perspective that are identified um
we can certainly make that information
available to you as um you know in a
timely way relative to the budget um so
all right do you have do you have more
of the i think that was three things you
might have said
no i don't um one i think maybe just
editorial or change that maybe is very
minor but if you're making a change
anyway on page five line four
rsa126a13 i think there's a comma
needs to be a comma and and then it says
and the commissioner i think it's and to
the commissioner because your proposed
changes you added to health and human
services oversight established in rsa
and to the commissioner otherwise it
doesn't
it i think we just need the right do it
kevin i think that's a good editorial
catch i think enrolled bills could have
taken care of it but if we got to open
up a fresh amendment we could just put
it in there
yeah
thank you mr chairman sorry i could just
ask uh clarifying questions so i assume
january thirty first on page six line
ten is being changed to june 30th
is the date also being
let me just ask a question before i
answer your question or um when when
does your data year end when is the data
collection supposed to end
so that all has to get figured out in
rule making um so this goes into effect
january 1st 2023 and we need rule making
um again we mirrored this process after
the quality commission they meet five
times a year and um and they
you know this is a little different
because of the data collection so um
i think we can make this all work um
i mean they will probably be collecting
the report is due annually let me just
annual report on page
two
uh
so i'm just trying to say if you're
whatever your data year you want it to
end if you want it to end june 30th then
it ends june 30th third of data but you
still give them 30 days to create the
report
because they've got to collect all the
okay does that is that what you're
expecting mr ripple
end the data collection on june 30th and
august 1
or 31 july
and the other is the commission's report
and i'm unsure what the ideal reporting
dates are for the two types
can you just strike dates and leave it
or do we or do we have to thumb wrestle
this to get
pinpoints
you could say um on page 6 line 10 the
commission shall annually report its
findings and leave it
blank blank okay
and and you can do that in the amendment
is there another date in there that we
there's a date for the individual
facility reporting
uh which is
on page
december 31st
yeah um
and i think you
you could do something similar here and
simply say the annual report as required
under paragraph five shall include and
remove any reference to a date
right so it would just say the annual
report for the calendar year or no for
uh whatever the annual report yeah
annual report
i don't know if the hospital association
has standardized from years ago being on
another committee it's like everyone had
a different fiscal year do you still
have that experience with the various
hospitals yes
yes so basically you'd want it at the
end of their fiscal year not not
necessarily because this doesn't um
impact them in that way um it's just we
need a uniform date for everyone to
submit the report so it's they collect
the data they will be
collecting the data
as they see fit
probably monthly for most hospitals um
as they compile their data and then
submit it annually or they may submit it
quarterly that's where i think rule
making will allow for some flexibility
hopefully and i would imagine even if
it's not done in rule making the
commission has enough adults on it they
can figure it out for the standard right
so i want i want to i want to try to put
some words in your mouth and see if you
agree or if you want to modify it
i i
i
i think
the hospital association
although this isn't what you anticipated
coming out of this committee that you
could live with it and we can work with
it and and we can
revisit it in the future
is this
are you going to oppose this amendment
uh no mr chairman we are not okay
we will
support so so thank you for that if um
now now you can say it in your own words
if you want if you're if you want to let
me know how disappointed you are in the
process that's okay too um
i'll all i will say is you know as i
said when i started this is an
incredibly important piece of
legislation one that um you know we've
worked on uh for many months um years uh
prior to this and this is an issue that
is of utmost importance to our members
you know
this is a legislative process
and it does not always end where it
begins um and you know we work through
the process to try and make it
as best as we can um
you said you know we shouldn't let
perfection be the enemy of the good um
and that's certainly true in many
instances
at the same time we have to make certain
that whatever that process whatever
comes out at the other end of the
process continues to support the the
ultimate goal um i think we've
we've come to a place that that we can
be supportive um certainly not where we
started what we would have uh what we
sought um but this is a a is a very
important and good first step and um we
will continue to work uh to make it
better um over the years as as we see uh
the experience with the the the
commission and and again preventing
violence in the workplace and protecting
the health uh and safety of our our
employees
uh thank you for all of that and and i
gotta say we could write the best law in
the world but we're not gonna prevent
violence uh well the best we can do is
mitigate it and get our people ready to
deal with it
but you know i i i if we could get rid
of violence in the world uh you know uh
putin would be on his yacht somewhere
you know so it's it i don't i i i just
the the reasonable objective here is
that we come up with a program that
attempts to mitigate
the risk and prepares the people to deal
with the incidents i think uh would you
take questions if the other
representatives have any
yes uh are there any other questions
uh representative long thank you i
hesitated to ask this question because
i'm afraid of the answer but uh you went
to a meeting of a national associate
national meeting
uh where other states are also working
on this
in your opinion where does this stand
towards other states i mean is this
proactive
i believe this is a very proactive
approach um many states have taken uh
steps to increase the penalties for
anyone uh who's convicted of striking a
health care worker um
we've not chosen to begin there um
because
just making something a stiffer penalty
or a higher level of crime doesn't
prevent uh the act from occurring in the
first place so what we said we needed to
do is to try and bring folks together to
understand what's happening how it's
happening how we prevent it um so again
i think this is a is an important first
step um and it's one that others can
certainly hopefully learn from great
all right not seeing any other questions
thank you uh i appreciate your tolerance
of of my sometimes emotional uh
reactions ms minihan
um but
this stuff is important uh to all of us
represer mr thomas
do you do you want to wave off or do you
have anything you want to say for the
nurses
thank you very much sean thomas demers
and praise all representing the new
hampshire nurses association
i will just echo
what the hospital association said in
that the goal here obviously is to
support and protect the safety of our
health care workers obviously in our
case
the state's nurses and i think
this amendment here having addressed
some of the concerns raised by the
hospital association today
um and all the work this committee has
done over the last several days and you
re in you mr chair
going back even before that when this
was in the policy committee i think
we've arrived at at a place now that you
know
in your words is something you know we
can live with and work with and so i
think uh so i appreciate your um
this committee's work on this bill
uh thank you are there any questions
from mr thomas nursing association
all right uh and go ahead chairman if
you don't mind it there was i i did
notice two technical edits and i figure
if there's an amendment no you're very
good at that please please point them
out uh so on page one
uh line 22
there is the new language here which
says shall address the following topics
and then or
i would recommend that be and
consistent with the shall
i the ore just seems confusing that's i
but that's you know take it or leave
that i'm not
not overly concerned
on
page two
is really
the one real technical change i think
was
that needs to be made and that's on line
four it says a process to report
workplace violence i think we need to
add there and hostile words
like we did it elsewhere
uh that's a good catch and the reason i
went with an or on the first one instead
of an and
is because i i didn't know that there
would be others that they would want to
add into the report and that makes sense
go ahead and add it
and then the very the last one just on
on line nine here and and
maybe this was an ols
um
change and and that's fine they you know
they maybe analyze this different than i
did but it seems like that or there on
all right i'm i'm okay with that again i
i'm
i'm trying to think of ores and ands and
my computer program in class and
so small things small things
uh all right is that is that it that's
all thank you very much and thank you
for your contributions to the drafting
of this um over the weekend and just
even last night i understand you you put
some stuff into mr ripple so so thank
you for that you're welcome thank you
and and then mr ripple
if if i if i really wanted the
principles of data minimization included
do you know where that would go
uh
so it's towards the back under
confidentiality
roman numeral
right above
administration
i see it
and i had the principles of data
minimization will be respected to
include de-identification so
de-identification is a subset of the
so i'd like i'd like the principle
referenced as well okay we can do that
all right
so
um i think we're getting close to
a vote
on
an amendment to this amendment and and
so miss ripple and with us all listening
has i think you've probably got about
six or seven tweaks something in that
neighborhood
yes
you want to walk through them and and
then i'm gonna uh do a straw vote if
we're gonna be okay with this sure um so
starting in the order
uh line 10
the reference to a specific reporting
date will be removed
i will read annually
with no date
on page two
on page 1 line 22 the or will be changed
the addition of hostile words i did not
actually get the page and line number
unfortunately i think it was uh
is on page two page two
i i don't want to rush it take take your
time i know that
there's a lot of detail also on page two
line 9
the principle of data minimization
will be added to
uh the paragraph that ends at the top of
okay
and there were two
very minor changes that i think we were
originally going to take care of in the
enrollment process but might as well
take care of them now they're both on
line 11 terms will be changed to term
and on line four we'll add a comma after
uh represent an organ
and i think the word two is added there
oh there was a two we added a two
somewhere
on line four oh to the commissioner okay
got it
and to the commissioner okay
do you think that's it
that's all that i have i don't know
representative irf did you want me to
address
the issue and the the definition of
health facility as long as we're in here
anyway
you might just take out the first
reference to yeah the fewer than three
of them that's covered with the sentence
you did add in at the end of that
definition so on page one line nine
where it reads uh or an urgent care
network of three or more clinics
licensed under rsa 151 that would come
out because that's already addressed on
don't move the reference to the license
part
just remove just change network of three
or more
clinics to um
urgent care
facilities what was the word that was in
the original oh right um
or urgent care
or urgent care facility would stay in
right
license under rsa licensed under rsa 151
so only uh the reference to a network of
three or right because that's what you
in line 13 and 14 you basically address
the three or more clinics
that specific line will read as it did
in the original bill or an urgent care
center licensed under rsa 151
correct
uh thank you okay
so
is anyone
needing miss ripple to repeat any more
of those tweaks
you have everyone is clear on what those
tweaks are okay
so so by a show of hands
i would like to see uh how many of the
committee would be willing to accept uh
that amendment
1864 with the tweaks and modifications
that mr ripple just described
so if you're in favor of that amendment
raise your hand
if you're opposed raise your hand and
see no one so um
so if we had a motion uh on this
representative irf we could second it
and
begin a vote
do you want to move the
the unusual changes that we just made or
just the whole thing has modified what i
what i'd like what i'd like to do is
have an amendment or
emotion
that uh
has us adopt
amendment 1864
as
corrected by
the mr ripples changes okay and that way
he can hopefully work on
having ols do the the last copy and
bring it to us while we're in in the
full finance committee to to to have our
vote so i would move
the motion otpa
with amendment number 2022-1864-h
to recommend that to the full finance
committee
second
and seconded
okay so maybe i should have included
with with the corrections as discussed
right so uh and second is acknowledges
that yeah okay so
um
is there any discussion further
discussion
mr williams i don't want to
lose track of the fact that i was going
to ask you if you had any words of
wisdom for us and
so
you don't you don't have to
okay i just i just didn't want to offend
you by not
giving you an explicit chance all right
all right
when the motion ought to pass as amended
by house uh amendment by amendment 1864
with the changes uh that we've just
worked on
if you're in favor you'll say yes when i
call your name otherwise you'll say no
representative eric yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
representative walner
representative nordgren yes
representative long yes
chairman edwards yes
mr chairman the vote is 7-0 all right
super we'll uh we'll we'll ask mr ripple
to try to get ols to crank it out and
we'll try to get it to vote um this
afternoon in our exact session so all
right so with that um
are there
any final words of wisdom i mean i i
look we we cranked through seven bills
some of them were really complex
in uh three business days and i don't
ever want to do that again but but we
but we did it so so i thank you for
showing up and putting in the work and
taking the time so so thank you for that
and and then with that um
uh division three is
you